hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to sneak-thief so if you
remember a very organized thief I don't
think this has anything to do with that
game it's only tangentially related and
I'm gonna make an assumption that it's
kind of similar and I don't know if
that's true don't look at me I'm not
sure of anything okay but either way
like the idea is kind of similar so I'm
gonna play the tutorial or at least when
I was looking at it it was like kind of
similar maybe you go into a place and
you steal stuff and that was kind of
what you know oh oh
press space to jump it's like the
half-life tutorial way back when oh look
at me oh look at me go
I'll take whatever the hell these are
sure gold bars I'm gonna believe you
about that man you get seven of those
you'd be set for hello oh god oh oh god
no oh God though he was so happy I got
gold bars you want me to murder these
people I know what you want ah what are
we gonna start off with a moral dilemma
alright sure or maybe like this isn't it
all what this was supposed to be it was
supposed to be these are the instructors
and it's like hey check out these Cooper
what are you doing oh god no not my face
oh oh no oh no oh no oh my god holy [ __ ]
this game I love it oh I can all I can
aim let me really get the bottom of
those feets
is there any party that does not have a
bullet hole
Oh God the WAMP on that gun glad they
actually caught the reality of the gun
here okay if you have collected enough
money you will be able to leave in the
escape vehicle all right okay I did it
let's go on a home invasion that I
imagine is gonna end in horrific murder
I'm going to be a terrible person
Hey I can't get caught if everyone that
ever saw me is dead oh boy okay so
there's my escape vehicle huh they'll
never see me coming
I'm gonna barge through that [ __ ]
door everyone good oh it's locked
god damn it they've warded me I guess uh
huh to go around can I cut the power
is that a logical thing that I can do oh
okay so zero zero
uh-huh three two okay three two no that
would be three one
oh that's the or zero hang on I gotta do
that again quickly oh [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
didn't see that that was there okay how
about hello Bella we're on three you
know that now [ __ ] it [ __ ] this reset it
I can't do it right okay let's try this
again
it's good thing that they put the code
right here boink okay 1 2 3 1 2 point 1
2 1 1 1 2 yeah hell yeah
alarm cut off they'll never see me
coming now
Oh cans of beans the most valuable of
stealable x' okay this looks exactly
like a very organized thief chica
good god you startled me pick up weapon
I don't wanna I don't wanna I don't
wanna murder why must you make me murder
aah aah don't murder I'll take that I
don't take that I'll just stuff that in
my bag butt cheeks you know I got an
infinitely spacious butt hole I can fit
just about anything up in there I've
never been tested to the full limits of
you
bottle of wine Vaz I'll take it
priceless bottles of wine that they
leave out on the shelf this is so very
organized thief there's a hundred
percent oh golden skull okay that
doesn't make any sense at all oh I got a
really make some space in my man cave
for this one okay there we go
take baseball bat that's good it's not a
weapon and I just pushed that freaking
thing into the ether there through the
wall
alright upstairs hope no one sleeping
boy that would be a mistake
no bathroom they got some valuables in
here priceless toilet maybe why do they
have another living room upstairs this
bizarre bank documents hell yeah oh
what's that
huh please swing swung at that hey can
you can you show me exactly what's on
there I want to know real bird Oh huh
eight six four seven huh is that a code
to a safety waify Oh someone trying to
hide something from me oh good they're
not in bed well I said they there's only
there's only one person bed so because
I'm not really concerned about Oh
someone's about to get whomped who wants
to get whomped I'm scared Mexica scared
I'm like cool come in here
are they there oh there's more bedrooms
oh I can still murder them where yet huh
they'll never see me coming he'll never
see me come you think they'd be a little
bit suspicious why do they have gold
bars goddamn thing eight six four seven
that was it right okay here we go eight
six four seven glad that was the
extremely PP one I wouldn't wanna have
those light beeping things okay I'm out
here baby I bet they're in that room so
they'll net Wow okay they they walked
right in the front door what a buncha
diat huh what a bun
chill losers they never saw me coming
what a bunch a-holes
totally ignorant and stupid oh good
the bank's easy don't I know it
let's get this going man what a bunch of
dill we owe a police officer but what a
loser
alright I'm scoping out this um maybe I
could bribe this guy hey buddy hey hey
buddy hey hey hey buddy hey hey you're
not those like those faceless mannequin
people that I murdered before can you
help me I'm pleading with you here my
you have beautiful eyes and your
chiseled jaw so sensual and glide 'fl I
love the way your hair looks like
plastic
you remind me of the Ken dolls that I
used to play with this child would you
like to play dress-up with me one more
time
please call me Barbie
call me barber sorry about that all
right
okay don't mind me I'm gonna go into
this bank and make a withdrawal I'm
gonna deposit some bullets into the
people in there there's a normal
activity I am normal human nothing wrong
going on here
hello sir please give me money you look
like my boxing coach all right
don't mind me sir you waitin on nothing
yeah oh okay oh is this for everybody on
my knee just meandering don't mind me
pearly here this is okay I'll take this
huh I mean they're never gonna find it
up my butthole so I guess I'm gonna be
okay they don't know anything has been
going on I see a ladder outside I'm
gonna make my way down there oh it's
hard to Waddle with all these paintings
up my butt but you know I'm gonna make
it man it's so now oh oh just got to
squeeze ha I shoulda done more squats in
school Oh Oh God oh why is it wet ah
okay anyway enough disgusting [ __ ]
who cut all power that sound good
Oh No Oh what happened dude all power go
gone no apparently not okay
habitat boopadoo where the hell is going
well do they have an attic what are the
internet ik password oh I don't know
what's the password
hi ah oh
wasn't me oh sorry about that didn't do
it there was me don't mind me don't mind
me
don't mind me come I mean it's nothing
don't worry about it's not nothing it's
nothing you're fine it's totally cool oh
my god is someone robbing you I I don't
know what to do oh I'm so scared
oh I'm so scared all right in the face I
was trying to surrender but you happen
to shoot me in the eye all right so the
moral the story is don't don't do that
okay so somewhere in this Bank there's
probably a code and it's not in there
this is the bunch
money over there but there must be there
must be something and sure that no one's
gonna know about ah it's under the book
isn't it oh it's so under that book I
could just I could just somehow oh I
could just move that book like you just
move that book just oh there we go
passwords bond lies cars back dogs Bank
cash bond cool shot cram mega book okay
and I'm gonna remember it by taking a
picture of it because I can't remember
anything okay so it's probably one of
those computer type do daddies that um
you you get it you do the thing and then
it gives you like a correct number of
letters because that would be really
convenient and definitely secure to have
it a bank okay so I got four tries at
this [ __ ] bond lies car back Bank cash
man cool shot grand mega and book so the
b-word seemed to be the best so I'm
gonna try Bank yeah ah so it's an a but
it's not a B so it's either cash or cars
so it's cash hey ho ho of course it's
cash cuz I'm gonna get a lot of oh oh oh
yes please and thank you please and
thank you oh please and thank you get
inside my rectum all there's more
there's so much more good god I'm not
gonna be able to press e enough to shove
this I'm gonna need more sports space
yeah okay alright okay now that I've
been encumbered properly let's get these
watches up in there
what do we got Oh more gold bars I
suppose I can take some you got kick
okay yeah we did it anything behind the
counter nope I guess I'm all done it
would probably be a bad idea to go out
that door because that probably leads to
something that would set off some kind
of an alarm oh no it's actually above
where does that door lead
no it's actually below it's actually
below I remember that goes downstairs ah
my legs Wow
I have over a million dollars inside of
my many cavities whoo yeah I don't feel
well okay that's good all right so that
was home invasion and back those are the
only two easy levels so let's do a
normal level let's do a normal one let's
see what it got for normal I don't know
if it's gonna be hard I bet it's not too
good of a thief let me go
oh wow
this is quite a house you got here I
suppose I can't just knock on the front
door Canon George long pick up weapon
ready buddy home heavy breathing me
Bliley hit me hit me hit me it was your
fault for leaving a hammer right out in
front yeah open up
Andy I can't exactly crawl through these
but at least I can do some vandalism
that's almost as good as robbing alright
fine I'm going around the okay oh hi oh
you're gonna get it hitting it whoa with
whoo hee whoo ow ow ow oh oh those the
silliest [ __ ] fight I've ever had alright
let's try that again
apparently there's a guy patrolling in
the backyard I did not know this alright
oh well that's convenient I guess I'm in
hacker voice I'm in was that oh it's
just like ok did it really their back
door just is wide open all the time
that doesn't seem logical ok though nice
house oh so nice goal Vaz gold Vaz
that's something that everyone had
silver vaz worth half as much as gold
one that doesn't make any sense
is chill anybody home
anybody ha whoa jeez UM's whoa hey whoa
wait whoa whoa eh whoa
you can't catch what you can't see oh I
want that ah my head why'd you have to
bap it take this you can't stop me I'm
shoving it inside me ha ha ha ha hey
whoa aah I'm okay I'm okay it's okay
you'll never catch me
you'll never know where I am I need a
wet pan oh I need something to smash
[ __ ] picked up the hammer from the
beginning but now they don't know where
I went
what a bunch of idiots ah they know
where I went oh they got me
what's in the fridge I just want to
stick yeah come over here come out come
at me bro oh what a bunch of stupids
okay
yeah we okay oh no the TV in my butt oh
I don't want to be on the balcony this
doesn't help anybody god damn door stop
opening that way oh I have a flashlight
I had a flashlight this whole time I'm
an idiot man for a mansion this house
doesn't have a whole lot I need to go
you go get the hammer
- [ __ ] BAM okay I'm locked and loaded
ready to go now I'm not gonna go home
yet I want more out of this house if I
have to smash every goddamn thing inside
of it I'm gonna do exactly that hey
buddy where'd your friend go y'all alone
now it's good thing I got unlimited
sprint I'm an Olympic level cardio
runner cuz that's an Olympic event
cardio running it's what they call it
don't ask me go blade fine artifact
artifact what does that mean artifact
hey stop it stop being a dick oh you
can't oh oh this weapon oh Jesus
this isn't this I shouldn't have this ah
they're gonna get me oh that hurt kind
of I think I'm not a hundred accenture I
I don't want to go away with just two
artifacts
I need more what is this take artifact
okay that was another artifact that was
worth exactly nothing I was a worth
nothing is stupid like yes that's
everything I I just don't know how to
get in the locked doors huh there is a
locked room up there but
lord knows if I know how to get to it
here's more whoa hello
I was just an alarm well too bad
I think they know I'm here I just have a
sneaking suspicion that they might have
some kind of inkling that I is here oh
let me do this will trigger what's this
boink oh it didn't do nothing ah can't
do it you'll have to see my trick later
hmm all right I guess that's all for now
there might be more secrets to this one
but I think I think I'm gonna be pretty
much done with this game so thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
want to see me finish this game let me
know in the comments down below it's a
little unrefined I need cigarettes out
more I leave okay I'll be right back
how you doing you guys look tired maybe
you want to lay down and go the [ __ ]
away
can I lock them out of the house if I
close this gate they won't be able to
get in will they oh oh look who got
locked out look who got locked out oh
there was more in here that's right huh
BAM
caboose key table F okay I got more than
enough money now they're gonna be
waiting for me at the gate but nothing I
can do about that hit oh oh no they lost
interest and they are gone okay I can't
hop over that can I where did they go oh
hello hello
Oh goodbye okay so now I think I'm done
so as soon as I get away that's gonna be
the end of this episode though thanks
again everybody so much for watching
hope you enjoyed this and there are a
few more levels but like I was saying
before it's a little unrefined it's not
exactly of the highest quality that I
would say and ordinarily I let this go
but this game cost money so I got to
give it a little bit of Christmas ISM
here on the slightly not quite done
nosov it I mean it says early access but
people sometimes just use early access
as an excuse to put games out there
before they're really ready for the
public but either way it's kind of fun
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always
you in the next video bye-bye I love
this fuzzy dog a lot o adorable dog Oh
long jump I mean how do you win this one
well screw you buddy I haven't even
begun to try